An IntentService is the base class for
services that are used to handle
asynchronous requests,
expressed as intents and done on demand.
Your app will send a request by starting
the service and passing it an intent.
If the service hasn't already started,
it will start if needed.
And it will handle each intent in turn,
using a worker thread.
When there are no more intents,
it will just stop itself.
It uses a single worker thread,
meaning that only one request
will be processed at a time.
But it won't block the application from
continuing doing what it needs to do.
In the next steps,
you'll create the IntentService class
called geofenceTransitions
IntentService.